For children experience is based on a single feature. For example height, not
necessarily height, weight, length, altogether. Children can't conserve,
meaning they don't release even if the shape changes, the volume the size and
the amount can stay the same. The classic example here is liquid. If one takes
two identical glasses and pour the exact same amount of liquid in each, then
ask them which one has more liquid. They're going to tell you they have the
same amount. But, if you take a short, fat glass like this and have them pour
it onto a tall, thin glass like this, and then ask them which one has more,
they're going to tell you that the tall, thin glass has more of the liquid.
Because the liquid comes up higher. This is a perfect example of them only
focusing on one feature, height. Older children and adults know that what we
gain in height, we lose in width. So, it's the exact same amount of liquid,
they're conserved. But younger children usually under the age of six, can't do
this mental calculation. They can be fooled by appearance.